curious how long was it until the
problem started coming what would you
say how many years I would say six years
in six years in I would say about six
years in would you would you say there
was like a switch that was flipped or
what did it did you see signs early on I
would say that I could say looking back
hindsight is 20 20. I'll be like ah you
missed that yeah you missed that oh you
missed that didn't you but because
there's a whole thing of when you're in
a relationship you're just in one and
people from the outside can see it which
is very interesting about love people
from the outside can say yeah I saw some
things and you're like no I love them
I'm cool everything's fine and that's
what and the thing is that's what
essentially what people are supposed to
do in relationships are not supposed to
allow people from the outside into there
I don't believe in allowing outside
people into your relationship
I don't believe that because I believe
that's one of the best ways for a
relationship to break down